[Music]
2021 seemed to be ryan reynolds big year
as the 45 year old canadian star in
three new movies three guy the hitmen's
wife's bodyguard and of course red
notice and even though we still have to
wait a long time for release of deadpool
3 another new movie with reynolds will
soon be coming to home theaters the talk
is of the adam project a kind of sci-fi
adventure film that revolves around a
time-traveling pilot named adam reed his
objective is to travel back in time
where he must team up with his 13 year
old self and his deceased father in an
attempt to save the future as director
sean levi told vanity fair reynolds is
not as lighthearted in this movie as you
might remember him from free guy instead
he is profoundly cynical and scarred by
life this can also be spawned in a total
of nine images from the netflix twitter
account where he is seen in various
scenes alongside his co-stars mark
ruffalo walker scoble zoe zaldana and
jennifer garner while hulk actor ruffalo
will play adam's father and jennifer
garner will play adam's mother we are
likely to see zoe zaldana in the role of
reynolds partner the antagonist of the
film is to be embodied by get out
actress catherine keener the adam
project will be released exclusively on
netflix on march 11 2022
shooting for the upcoming guardians of
the galaxy vol 3 has been ongoing since
the end of last year and piece by piece
new information is also coming to light
in deadlines hero nation podcast gun
recently spoke out about the third
adventure of starlord and the others
which as we have known since last year
will also be his last guardians film
anyone who had previously hoped that we
will then see further parts from another
director has now been sadly disappointed
why you ask well it's because gunn
confirmed that guardians of the galaxy
vol 3 will definitely also be the final
part of the franchise he literally said
he wanted to stay true to the characters
and the story and give audiences the
closure they deserve likewise he gave
some hints as to what the movie will be
like accordingly it will be huge of
course but above all it will be gloomy
and a little different from what some
fans might expect this is certainly
associated with the death of one or more
characters which is in line with an
earlier interview with nebula actress
karen gillian in said interview with
yahoo movies she claimed she actually
had to cry while reading through the
script on may 5th 2023 we will know more
because that's when guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 is scheduled to be released
in theaters
one topic in particular dominated the
film world at the end of last week and
that was the casting of jason momoa for
the upcoming fast and furious 10. while
nothing is known about the plot of the
penultimate fast and furious installment
there are at least a few theories as to
what role aquaman star mamoa might take
on the most persistent rumor is that
momoa will be playing the bad guy
well at least that's what deadline
claims but they also admit to simply not
having enough information on this script
at this point the second option would be
casting him as a protagonist alongside
vin diesel thus a role similar to the
one dwayne johnson held as luke hopps
well we would not like to comment on
which version is more likely at this
time either way one person should be
particularly pleased and that is dwayne
johnson after all following his dispute
with vin diesel he was literally pleaded
to return to the franchise and bring it
to a nice harmonious end momoa at least
in contrast to the often controversial
vin diesel is considered a fan favorite
and is likely not only to balloon the
production budget with his feet but he
may also be the anti-thesis of dom
toretto who has been repeatedly called
for since lukhov's split fast and
furious 10 is set for release on may 19
2023
the loki series on disney plus opened up
the multiverse which is so important for
phase 4 of the mcu and thus it also
paved the way for movies like spiderman
no way home or the upcoming doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
now barely a year after the release of
the first season the second season is
already to be shot as the portal
backstage reports filming is scheduled
to start as early as this summer with
pinewood studios neal london being the
shooting location no longer involved
will be director k herron who had
already ruled out a new commitment in
advance which probably was due to the
very late communication of season 2. we
hope that at least in front of the
camera familiar faces like own wilson or
google mathera will be back should they
be able to stick to the schedule we will
get to watch the second season on disney
plus at the beginning of 2023
foundation is definitely one of the
bigger names on the apple tv plus
streaming service the science fiction
series revolves around a story taking
place in the future where humanity is no
longer confined to earth but scattered
across many different planets throughout
the galaxy at the top of the food chain
is the so-called galactic empire which
governs the various human colonies the
first season mainly centered around four
characters who try to do their utmost to
secure the future of the human species
in extremely unstable times thus all
must be done to counter the collapse of
the galaxy and for this purpose the
so-called foundation was established by
dr harry selden the cast around jared
harris lee pace lou lavelle and leah
harvey is now growing a lot for season
2. let us introduce you to a few new
characters first there's dimitri
leonida's playing hobart mallow he's a
cunning merchant operating according to
his very own morals and wants nothing
more than to ply his trade in addition
there's bel rios who's embodied by ben
daniels he's the last great general of
the superliminal fleet and as a soldier
he's naturally committed mainly to the
galactic empire although this trust
seems to be dwindling evermore isabella
loveland on the other hand plays the
cheerful cleric brother constant who
spreads her teachings throughout the
galactic empire and is a thoroughly
convinced believer in her faith her
counterpart is the cleric paulie varies
of who besides his drinking problem is
utterly cynical and has a razor sharp
mind he is portrayed by kolvinder gear
there's also sandra yes and sendaiver as
anjonaroo who is an advisor to crane
cereth who in turn will be played by
lray smith the queen in particular will
make clever use of her role as the
underdog especially since she has a
great vendetta planned besides the
actors just mentioned holt mckellen
michael pursebrand rachel house and
nimrod carr will also be joining the
cast sadly it is not yet known when
exactly foundation season 2 will be
released on apple tv plus
as every year the world is looking
forward to the most important sports
event of the year the 2022 super bowl
between the los angeles rams and the
cincinnati bengals the finale of the nfl
will not only feature a top class
halftime show by eminem snoop dogg mary
j blige kendrick lamar and dr dre but
also all kinds of new trailers for
upcoming movies and series at last year
super bowl movie fans were rather
disappointed as theaters were still
closed in many major locations like los
angeles and new york city this year
things are also unusually quiet as far
as rumors from the major studios are
concerned however that doesn't mean that
we cannot expect any surprises for one
thing there's universal which is
traditionally one of the more active
studios at the super bowl just think
about the miami appearance back then
when the fast and furious knight trailer
was phenomenally supported by
performances from various artists
involved in the film this year we expect
to see new material on jurassic world
dominion and minions the rise of crew as
both will be released at the beginning
of june and july also conceivable would
be your first look at jordanfield's
latest horror flag nope due for release
a bit later in july paramount will
likewise take the opportunity to show
off some new footage in the first place
there should be a second trailer for
sonic the hedgehog 2 which is set for
release at the beginning of april a
third trailer for top gun maverick would
not be a bad idea either since the film
is scheduled for release at the end of
may after countless delays the plans for
streaming giant's netflix and amazon are
significantly less clear the us media is
relatively certain that netflix will
show the trailer for the atom project
starring zoe zelda and ryan reynolds
while amazon will promote his broadcast
rights to the popular sports show
thursday night football last but not
least there's disney it stands to reason
that we will get to see trailers for
moon night doctor strange 2 and the
light year and by the way our colleagues
from warner brothers apple and sony are
expected to traditionally remain on the
sidelines again what are your
expectations for this super bowl which
trailers should not be missing in your
opinion and are you expecting to see the
one or other surprise feel free to write
us in the comments
we hope you enjoyed our news again this
week be sure to check out our channel
for the movie preview of predator 5 prey
and do not miss the new trailer for the
halo series which is a must-see not only
for gaming fans
[Music]